Normally, we don't like to talk about youtube drama
but there's something going on right now that transcends that.
As you may know,  h3h3 is being sued by
another youtuber because they used his
work in one of their videos.
Now to everyone on this platform that seems
totally normal because the expectation
is when you put something on YouTube you
are putting it before a public forum and
if other people want to comment on that
material they have the right to do so,
So long as they add something and they keep it
creative and they generally give you credit.
Now, that's a lot different than
the way that things used to be and the
crux of the issue here is that there's a
problem with copyright law and the way
that it was written and originally intended.
Not only as a member of Corridor Digital
but as a lawyer in the state of California
I think it's super important that we take a moment to
examine not only what's before h3h3 here,
but what it means for the rest of the platform and for the future of copyright law.
There's a lot of assumptions about what fair use is
so let's clarify what it is and what it's not
The first thing to remember is that fair use
is not a right, it's a defence.
In order to argue an
affirmative defense you must present it
to a fact-finder ie a judge or jury before the
court and only under the facts of your
particular case. Therefore, you must go
through a lengthy and costly court
process in order to assert this defense
and that's exactly why the h3 h3 case is
taking so long and costing so much money
when they have their day in court the
judge will look to four factors to
determine whether or not the various
defence applies. Number 1: He will look to
the purpose and character of the use.
Now, this one is very important the
judge will be looking to see if whether
or not when h3h3 took the
video from the other youtuber and put it
in their own, they added something to
that youtuber's video. In this particular
case, they put three minutes of another
youtuber's video in between 11 minutes
of their own creative commentary but
they didn't actually touch or affect
the other youtubers work so it
ultimately comes down to the judge or
jury to decide whether or not placing
someone else's video in-between moments
of constructive creative comedic
commentary is in and of itself
transformative or if it's not because
they just took it and placed it and then
added stuff of their own separately.
If h3h3 wins, it will set a
precedent that says their style of video
creating does fall under the first
factor of fair use. The second factor
that the judge will look at is the
nature of the copyrighted work itself
and whether or not that work is strongly copyrightable.
Is it original? Is it unique?
The answer is yes and this factor
actually does fall in that other
youtubers favor. Number 3: the judge
will look to the amount and substantiality
of the portion used in relation to the
copyrighted work as a whole. Here, h3h3 used
the entire video which traditionally is
a bad thing but just like in the music
industry, where the courts had to come
up with a guideline so that musicians could
cover other musicians songs, the same
thing is happening here but the law
hasn't caught up yet. People online
considerate it entirely fair and normal to take
someone else's video and add something
to it. You look at the way that Mike Diva
has done dubstep remixes, you look at the way
that h3h3 has done comedic
commentary on other people's videos.
This goes on across the board and
it's considered acceptable by the
community. But the law hasn't caught up yet
this is exactly where the problem lies.
At number 4, the court will consider
the effect of the new use on the market
of the original copyrighted work.
Does the new use add value or takeaway value
from the original copyright? In this case
I think h3h3's use definitely
adds value to the original youtuber's
video because it gets him more views it
gets his name out there and it overall
adds value to his channel across the platform.
As you can see this case
ultimately comes down to two things
whether or not the court will consider h3h3's
use to be transformative and
whether or not they will consider the
type of use
that's being made across the digital
community to be fair much in the same
way that they had to recognize musicians
making covers of other people's songs
the problem is they haven't quite caught
up with this yet, and if h3h3 is able to win
this case on this fair use defense, it
will set precedent for the rest of the
digital space and the rest of our
community and this is what makes this
case super super important.
For all of you who supported h3h3 in this fight or
even just add to the conversation that's
happening right now
thank you it's very important.
It's going to mean a lot for
it's going to mean the world it's guys
it means the world to us. It's gonna be a
lot, not just for Ethan and Hilla, but for
the world
Did you understand all that?
it's a hard day and I'm and it's what
were thinking about all the time
hopefully I'll find out this month if
i'll be in financial ruin the rest of my
life or not
fifty-four thousand dollars it's like
we're fucked no matter what happens.